tout semble calme et pourtant un drame
se joue au château un procès en
sorcellerie
après les templiers l'année dernière le
thème de ces fêtes cette année sont donc
les sorcières et le pain en fonction
évidemment le train entrait en aide à
beaucoup de choses
les formules magiques tout à l'heure
pour guérir d'une morsure d'un animal un
chien enragé
c'était ce qu'on faisait en médiéval au
moyen âge donc on n'y comprenait mort ce
temps on était les fours nul et on y rit
cité datant du xiiie siècle la
forteresse était l'un des derniers
remparts du royaume à l'époque à un
moment où le domaine royal donc et elle
est extrêmement limitée autour des île
de france lorsque le roi de france par
exemple il pollue story 6 legros
entreprenait d'aller de paris et orléans
et bien il empruntait ce qu'on
appellerait aujourd'hui la voie
stratégique du royaume qui était protégé
par différentes fortifications donc
yèvre le châtel étampes dourdan et ses
fortifications protéger cette voix qui
permettait au roi données sur notamment
soit val de loire bien loin du tumulte
de l'histoire les enfants doivent
maintenant parcourir les salles du
château à la recherche d'un disque qui
leur permettront de trouver la réponse à
une énigme
c'est bien cherché si on plonge existe
dans un court et quand on l'a trouvé ce
n'était pas amusant pour un des
activités et les sorcières et son
méchant
demain damoiselles sorcières et
chevalier vous attendent pour les
derniers spectacles de ces journées
médiévales